- I want to get all you guys involved,
reach into your bags,
your pockets,
get something out that you
would like me to rap about.
Even if you're over there.
(hip hop track starts)
Even if you're down on
these weird little beanbags
at the back, okay?
Get something out.
I'm going to walk amongst
you rap about those things.
While you're doing that,
I'm going to get this magical helmet,
which people tell me will
keep me safe from Coronavirus.
When I'm getting close to
all your unvaccinated faces,
let's drop that beat. I'm
going to walk amongst you.
We're going to rap about this stuff,
Okay. Let's jump down here.
Make sure this is on full blast mode.
This is the first thing
we're starting with.
We're starting very simple guys,
but don't worry.
Nice.
♪ Front row, ♪
♪ Get involved, you intend ♪
♪ Clicking on here, Filantis on the pen ♪
♪ That's the name of the
company you work for ♪
♪ I like it clicking on the bottom ♪
♪ I adore ♪
♪ Color of the ink may be blue ♪
♪ Pick another, ♪
♪ The Red Bull sugar-free I discover ♪
♪ I gave it to my brother. I shake it up ♪
♪ I'm like a teen ♪
♪ Getting energetic with the caffeine ♪
♪ Is ever so crazy ♪
♪ I keep myself up at night ♪
♪ Bringing the mouse to
the convention, why ♪
♪ It's so confusing? ♪
♪ You want to get respect, collect ♪
♪ Clicking all around with the Logitech ♪
♪ That's the truth, Bluetooth. ♪
♪ And I'll say ♪
♪ A weird little thing
like the top of a cray-on ♪
♪ Maybe I can look inside, see a drop ♪
♪ Like a tiny little nipple,
and it's from the Body Shop ♪
♪ Strange ♪
♪ Put it there on your
teat, on your boob ♪
♪ Looking kind of offensive ♪
♪ But though, dude ♪
♪ Don't even matter ♪
♪ Anything for this little rapper ♪
♪ If you've got the
breath that be badder ♪
♪ I like to put elastic around my ears ♪
♪ Protect me from the virus ♪
♪ A face mask three ply.
Yes, I provide this ♪
♪ And this guy. Yeah ♪
♪ He got more dough ♪
♪ Hundred more Euros
for the Air Pods Pro ♪
♪ Careful that they don't
break and don't lose one ♪
♪ Some money, bye guys
here I'm just move on ♪
♪ Euros in a baggie. What's that thug ♪
♪ It doesn't make sense ♪
♪ Maybe you exchange it for the drugs ♪
♪ When it's there, in the little Ziploc ♪
♪ Earring from your ear, kind of clean ♪
♪ When I Hip Hop ♪
♪ I could walk around, pendant ♪
♪ Dangling from my lobe.
You should disinfect that ♪
♪ Now that I've chose,
I've really touched that ♪
♪ What is this? Let me see ♪
♪ It's a hair tie with
the symbol infinity ♪
♪ Goin' round. Never even hate ♪
♪ Turn it that way,
vertical, number eight ♪
♪ And now to my dude. Oh, it's not hard ♪
♪ It's Marty Delo. He
just provides his card ♪
♪ It doesn't have your name.
It just says global logistics ♪
♪ Is this company good? Yeah ♪
♪ I will slip it in my
pocket. And now this ♪
♪ For this fella ♪
♪ If it starts raining ♪
♪ Pop up this umbrella, it says Pizarro ♪
♪ That's never a brand
that I've heard before ♪
♪ But y'all understand. It's unlucky ♪
♪ What you guys giving me
a thing? Ooh, very nice ♪
♪ It's a little ring ♪
♪ It likes to monitor yourself
with the lasers inside ♪
♪ I've got my own bling ♪
♪ Yeah, the rings I provide ♪
♪ And this is your lanyard. Hello ♪
♪ From the university.
That's Laura Tillow ♪
♪ It says visitor. Oh,
like the polo shirt ♪
♪ Like the blue color, yeah,
I won't flirt anymore ♪
♪ Here's a little card ♪
♪ So many on the clean,
strawberry on the back ♪
♪ So messy ♪
♪ Why have you got the dirt on the side ♪
♪ It goes well, you and I
goin' back to your hotel ♪
♪ I'll mosey on over here ♪
♪ Yeah I think, the wifi
password with the pink ♪
♪ It's just got this. Let
me give you a suggestion ♪
♪ It says what's the wifi password ♪
♪ That's the question that
you were going to ask ♪
♪ Yo, Chris ♪
♪ I've got a query, ♪
♪ Voss the sport water ♪
♪ Don't fear me when the beat drops ♪
♪ Grateful flavor, run a hop on it ♪
♪ The vitamins and minerals ♪
♪ The isotonic. If you're hung over ♪
♪ Yeah. I might glower ♪
♪ Do a frown at the guy,
and it says ice power ♪
♪ This is pretty great.
You and I could click ♪
♪ You do first aid. So solve
it if the flow's so sick ♪
♪ And now from Sim ♪
♪ Here's a little battery pack ♪
♪ Got a little wifi,
recharge, I'm having that ♪
♪ Put it on my phone, hold
it in your little gilet ♪
♪ Oh photo. Hi mum ♪
♪ I'm glad to say, a key
ring coming from so far ♪
♪ You like repping VW there on the car ♪
♪ In the bum bag, that's a nice position ♪
♪ Were you upset when they
lied about the emissions ♪
♪ It got you in the throat
with the Volkswagen Golf ♪
♪ Some lipstick, put it
there right above your fro ♪
♪ Kiko, Milano. Let's discover ♪
♪ I'm going to look in here ♪
♪ It's a nice fuchsia color ♪
♪ I might think some people
would describe it as pink ♪
♪ Looking elegant. Like
you're wearing a mink ♪
♪ It's me on the phone
for a ten second clip ♪
♪ This is so damn old, Yeah, you
should flip it in a new one ♪
♪ What's this an iPhone six
or a more nicer one? Whoa ♪
♪ You think I'm a dick.
Looking at me, sayin' ♪
♪ There we go ♪
# I'm jealous of the turtle
neck from this fellow. Oh
♪ Real nice thing.
Comedy, such a charmer ♪
♪ We could eat this and then
peel, slip on a banana ♪
♪ It's looking very long.
We're having such fun ♪
♪ Only rapper on the stage
pose in a lack of gun ♪
♪ We begun ♪
♪ Any other things from this chap? ♪
♪ There, an Apple watch ♪
♪ Take it off your wrist, don't care ♪
♪ Let me see the weather. I
shout it out loudly, Tatu ♪
♪ 14 degrees and cloudy.
And let me talk about this ♪
♪ I'm glad we asked, ♪
♪ How the heck do you keep
this on your mustache ♪
♪ It's going over there ♪
♪ You'll never let it relax ♪
♪ You've got to get a little tub ♪
♪ And you whip and now wax like ♪
♪ Oh yes. I'll say it again ♪
♪ I'm looking ever so posh ♪
♪ Like Victorian ♪
♪ Like an Explorer. There,
I'm glad we're havin' fun ♪
♪ I'm in Tartu ♪
♪ You should be in the Amazon ♪
- There we go
(crowd applauds)
Oh boy. Oh boy.
Oh boy.
You guys have been real, real nice.